you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar overcoming the challenges of
accuracy and detection and molecular
assays I am Alexis Krause elaborate and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific to learn more about
our sponsor please visit thermo Fisher
comm now let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send well answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Peter Holden
senior business development manager
molecular diagnostics licensing and
commercial supply at Thermo Fisher
Scientific
Cedar's current role is in supporting
customers who purchase Thermo Fisher
Scientific products for commercial use
with a particular focus in supporting
the use of molecular biology and sample
preparation products for inclusion into
diagnostic kits
gives over 15 years of experience in
commercial sales and is responsible for
Ion Torrent sequencing capillary
electrophoresis real-time pcr and
molecular biology products prior to
joining Thermo Fisher Scientific Peter
led a research group and molecular
toxicology at AstraZeneca after
receiving his doctorate in plant biology
for the use at the University of nm
Edinburgh
dr. Holden you may not begin your
presentation
well good morning good afternoon and and
thank you for the introduction yes
today's presentation I will cover some
of the challenges facing researchers
developing a molecular diagnostic test
and I will review options that are
available available to overcome these
challenges including enzyme development
lastly I'll wrap up with the quality and
manufacturing commitment from thermo
Fisher Scientific and how we can partner
with you in the development of a
diagnostic assay
so what is the importance of a
point-of-care test a point-of-care test
allows rapid detection of analytes near
the patient's which will facilitate a
better disease diagnosis monitoring and
management the disease can be diagnosed
at a very early stage enabling a quick
medial decision and treatment which
leads to improved outcomes for patient
health based on market research reports
immunoassays account for the largest
market share for diagnostic testing
however by utilizing nucleic acid
amplification technologies molecular
tests are highly sensitive and specific
with high-throughput capability as
compared to amino acids many of these
molecular assays are performed on
portable plaque walls that can be run in
community clinics on most remote areas
of the world setting a new bar for a
true point of care diagnostic assay
so what is the workflow for a molecular
test
it begins with the sample the DNA and
all the RNA today real-time PCR
is at the heart of numerous diagnostic
assays with this potential for
quantification enabling assessment of
DNA copy number variation differential
RNA expression levels and pathogen load
whereas the original PCR protocols
assess individual markers the trend now
is towards testing for multiple targets
in a single assay what we'd call a
multiplex which not only allows for -
put testing but also reduces cost and
the time taken to complete the assay for
our presentation will focus on the
amplification method used in real-time
PCR
you
so there are many challenges to overcome
when preparing purified target material
for qpcr one such challenge is the time
to prepare material which makes it
susceptible to environmental and sample
borne inhibitors
to detect the underlying molecular
changes in a diagnostic test a variety
of specimen types are needed which may
include cells from buccal swabs saliva
blood frozen or paraffin-embedded tissue
stool samples and and many other types
however many of these samples have
inhibitory factors and the presence of
these factors such as feminine blood can
result in the inhibition of the
amplification reaction resulting in
false negative results other challenges
include carryover of enzyme inhibitors
from extraction the agents and poor
yield which is further complicated by
lower amounts of impact target DNA in
the purified sample for example blood is
a common sample type cancer blood tests
work by screening for cell free DNA
releasing released by dying tumor cells
these tests known as liquid biopsies are
showing promise but not only for the
detecting cancer DNA but also monitoring
treatment progress tumor DNA makes only
a fraction of the total of CF DNA thus
to avoid false negatives
Miney amounts need to be detected and
significant amounts of DNA needs to be
obtained to avoid biases and artifacts
this is further hindered by inhibitors
present in blood itself or coming from
blood stabilizers or purification
as you develop a molecular assay the
choices you select the DNA RNA
extraction are interconnected to
amplification steps especially in the
enzyme choice traditional enzymes such
as tack DNA polymerase which are less
tolerant of inhibitors will require
cleaner sample therefore more investment
into the DNA RNA extraction step is
needed however the better application
enzymes are available at a tolerant of
inhibitors than the requirement for
highly purified targets is less critical
not only do better amplification
times need to be tolerant of inhibitors
but they can also offer improvement in
other areas within your molecular assay
these our areas could be areas such as
accuracy really detection with a faster
turnaround time fewer steps or processes
for ease of use for the operator a
room-temperature stable format for ease
of storage at multiplexing as we've
mentioned but lastly I'm probably the
reliable and robustness for a variety of
sample types is critical in developing
your molecular assay in this section I
will review the key properties of a
preferred enzyme in detail which will
include the following multiplexing to
increase the number of target per
reaction and conserve precious samples
processivity which is the greater
affinity for the template inhibitor
resistance and and working with
challenging samples
another area's thermal stability room
temperature stable variance as well as
thermal stability to alleviate elements
such as secondary structure
the 50 and speed are also critical speed
as measured by the number of nucleotides
incorporated per second
provides higher throughput and faster
time to diagnosis
multiplex PCR technology allows
simultaneous detection of multiple
nucleic acid targets in a single
reaction as compared to a single Plex
reaction
the gel data shown here is an example of
hot star platinum - DNA polymerase in
multiplexing 15 targets in a single PCR
reaction the advantage of multiplex PCR
and a diagnostic test is that it
increases the number of targets in the
single reaction and reduces the sample
requirement and eventually and
ultimately conserves precious materials
the next key attribute of a better end
enzyme is processivity which is the
ability of an enzyme to catalyze
consecutive reactions without releasing
its substrate as shown in this
illustration highly process of enzymes
incorporate a higher number of
nucleotides put binding event and with
this results in much longer applicants
you
you
due to a high affinity for the template
these highly possessive enzymes are more
tolerant of inhibitors as shown here in
a figure and in particular in Figure a
inhibitors like heparin or formalin have
a minimal effect on a high projective
enzyme such as super script for reverse
transcriptase in the cDNA synthesis step
as compared to enzymes with low
processivity
figure B shows that a highly possessive
enzyme can synthesize C DNA from
degraded RNA more efficiently than
standard enzymes
the VAR na is used as a starting
material then high level of RNA
secondary structure can cause a problem
for the cDNA synthesis step an attribute
of a better enzyme is one to form at
higher temperature where secondary
structure is alleviated as seen here by
this by this figure in this illustration
you
the solution shows that RNA templates of
varying lengths will reverse transcribed
at different temperatures using a highly
thermal stable engineered mm LV reversed
attempt at reverse transcriptase the
results indicate them a stability of the
enzyme with a hundred percent activity
even at fifty six point four degrees
centigrade
specificity of an enzyme is another
property important to a diagnostic assay
because of the precise interaction of
the target template with the enzyme one
feature is to use a hot start DNA
polymerase enzyme which will only be
activated at a specific temperature
which is convenient if requiring room
temperature setup
in this jail data a PCR reaction was
performed after setup at room
temperature using platinum to tack DNA
polymerase here we can see that there is
no nonspecific amplification even after
17 to 72 hours incubation at room
temperature
I'm a sad to figure PCR reactions were
prepared and incubated at room
temperature for zero 24 and 72 hours
before loading into a thermo cycler
highly specific amplification of a two
kilobase fragment from human genomic DNA
was observed even after 72 hours after
room temperature setup demonstrating the
power of hot start DNA polymerase is for
large-scale experiments
you
in Figure a as you can
the slide we have another gel which
shows the absence of nonspecific of a
nonspecific amplicon with hot start DNA
polymerase
in addition in Figure be highly high
specificity can be enhanced with Surma
stable enzymes as seen at higher
temperatures
these are PPR results from non hot start
versus hot start DNA polymerases please
note the improved yields of the desired
amplicon and the lack of nonspecific
amplification with a hot start DNA
polymerase reverse transcription and an
elevated temperature enhances PCR
specificity mRNA for four different
genes was reverse transcribed at
different temperatures using oligo DT or
gene specific primers of varying
scription at 55 degrees centigrade
generated high specificity of the
desired target in the rt-pcr reaction
you
enzyme speed is important since it will
improve time to result in a molecular
test the example shown here is a
15-second PCR amplification as compared
to a typical application it might take
30 minutes or more
you
so do you need all these enzyme
properties for your molecular assay
as you develop your assay and review
these different attributes
you must understand there has to be a
trade-off for example do you use a
better enzyme to overcome sub optimal
samples against or versus a lengthy
sample processing step to obtain your
purified target so that has to be taken
into consideration
in the next section I will present
information on advances made in enzyme
development by thermo Fisher Scientific
which will help you make better choices
in assay development
we use several approaches and developing
a better enzyme first start with the
protein design to obtain an enzyme with
the desired phenotype second
in the buffer formulation and optimize
for specific applications and then
lastly implement single use technology
to manufacture enzymes that contain with
contaminating DNA below the limit of
detection
so let's take a look at these approaches
in more detail
the classic approach to pro
design is to isolate from a natural
source such as tack polymerase from
thermos aquaticus that lives in hot
springs and hydrothermal vents
however this method relies heavily on
luck to obtain the desired feature
Roach is by rational design an example
of this is the superscript to reverse
transcriptase which is a point mutation
in the gene encoding the Maloney murine
leukemia virus FML v reverse
transcriptase this method requires
knowledge of the domain or the amino
acids of the enzyme
the last approach is protein evolution
also referred to as directed evolution
this method mimics the process of
natural selection to steer proteins
towards a desired feature with no prior
knowledge of protein structure or
function needed
so this seems quite desirable how how
does it actually work
the process starts with the gene
encoding for a wild type or unmodified
enzyme of interest
random variation is introduced into the
genes or a process of mutagenesis
generating a library of millions of
genes
each encoding for you
I'm very functional selection pressure
using for example higher temperatures
is then applied to the library where
only the genes that coded for the
highest performing enzymes actually
survive this process of random mutation
selection is repeated until the desired
enzyme function evolves
directly relation enables us to engineer
improvement to end line functions such
as processivity them stability a more
tolerant to inhibitors these evolved
enzymes are different from other
engineered enzymes because they have
been optimized for specific functions
to further the development of bed
enzymes we can also utilize gene fusion
technology to insert a protein domain
with a desired feature into the novel
enzyme
one of the thermo Fisher enzymes fusion
DNA polymerase is an example of gene
fusion which brings together a process
Civet ian hansung domain with a pyro
caucus like also known as PFU enzyme
so utilizing a combination of methods
Thermo Fisher Scientific has developed
several new generation of of enzymes
such as platinum to tack
DNA polymerase and superscript for
reverse transcriptase that can help
overcome some of the challenges you face
in developing molecular diagnostic
assays
you
Platinum to tack hot start DNA
polymerase was designed by two
innovative technologies the polymerase
was engineered by protein evolution for
higher speed and resistance to PCR
inhibitors
while an innovative pcr buffer enabled
the universal annealing temperature
in the top panel the Platinum two tax
shows higher tolerance to common PCR
inhibitors as compared to other
commercially available DNA polymerases
some panel the
your platinum to tack for faster DNA
synthesis so fast cycling can result in
an overall reduction in PCR time
these features are critical to any
diagnostic assay especially when working
with sub-optimal sample types and when
requiring a fast turnaround time and
detection
you
similar to platinum to tack superscript
for reverse transcriptase was also
designed by protein evolution for speed
and resistance to inhibitors and an
optimized buffer formulation in the top
panel
graph demonstrates that superscript for
RT resulted in the lowest CT value when
compared to our commercially available
artis in addition the reaction time for
superscript 4 is 10 minutes
compared to say 30 to 60 minutes for the
other reverse transcriptase
and
our panel inhibitors can interfere with
CDA services such as MN has very little
effect on the performance of superscript
for reverse transcriptase
you
you
the five covered protein designs an
optimized buffer formulation for the
development of better enzymes in the
next section
you
I would like to present the use of
single use technology for enzyme
manufacturing
how does manufacturing impact the
performance of better enzymes
various publications it is known that
commercially-available tack polymerase
is contain various streams of bacterial
DNA as you can see here this is quite a
detailed slide but you know gives it a
strong illustration of the number of
species can be found within DNA
enzymes are typically contaminated with
bacterial DNA and other contaminants
during manufacturing most of these
enzymes are recombinant protein
expressed in e.coli therefore therefore
it's not surprising that they will
contain some bacterial DNA as seen in
this graph of over Q PCR assay using
note and no template control here in the
bottom left hand corner
you
you
an uncontrolled DNA contamination in
tactical emerets used in a molecular
acid can compromise both sensitivity and
specificity of an assay
using a closed single use system as we
call suf
disposable single-use components such as
salsas bags and columns are connected by
sterile single-use tubes for everyday
for sorry for every stage of the
production
the closed systems ensure that an entire
process is never exposed to the
surrounding environment or the operator
you
the product from this
innovation is a DNA free
DNA polymerase
shows two graphs of qPCR acids performed
using the DNA free platinum tack this is
commercially available DNA polymerases
and both the test is to the absence of
signal and a no template control no
amplification
was observed in DNA free platinum tack
whereas presence of contaminating DNA
and other enzymes can lower analytical
sensitivity of a molecular assay since
the signal of the contaminating DNA can
interfere with detection of low copy DNA
targets
the tight quality control for DNA free
enzymes provides an increase confidence
in the sensitivity specificity and
record usability of your molecular assay
especially for low copy DNA target
detection
you
as more point-of-care taps of being
developed so is the demand for
room-temperature storage and stability
of assays
unfortunately the majority commercially
available bands commercially available
enzymes on the market are incompatible
due to the presence of glycerol in the
enzyme buffer
our solution is a liar ready analog that
contains the glycerol level below 0.5%
and still retains the functions and
performance of enzymes containing
glycerol
so with considerable experience in
identifying and optimizing buffer
formulations and lyophilizer we offer a
large portfolio of library enzymes such
as superscript for reverse transcriptase
that can meet the highest standards of
performance required in your molecular
assay
you can see from the figure that this
enzyme performs the same in various
formats ie in lire ready format laughs
alized reconstitute reconstituted and
also the standard literal formats
so this data is sharing the effect of
buffer pH on thermo stability the
protein thermal shift assay was used to
screen for various for the effect of
various buffer concentrations on rec a
thermal stability data from the protein
thermal shift software shows the
Boltzmann upper panel and derivative
lower panel melt profile of buffer a ph
5.5 gotta be at pH 6 C & 7 & D at 7.5
the the data was collected at 1 degree
centigrade intervals from 25 degrees C
through to 99 degrees centigrade on
applied by system step 1 plus with time
PCR machine and analyzed with the
protein thermal shift software
you
you
these new generation of enzymes which
will be customized to meet your
individual specification are
manufactured in our Vilnius biosensors
Biosciences center of excellence
the fightin has over 40 years of
experience our expertise in enzyme
development and reagent manufacturing
and the facility employs
state-of-the-art equipment it's capable
small scale to multi liter volumes of
reagent production the capacity and
flexibility of our production facility
enables us to respond quickly to any
throughput requirements
you
you
understands the importance
of adhering to either quality standards
when developing supplying reagents for
molecular assays all production works
performed in accordance with ISO
management systems which means we are
committed to being a reliable partner
that has a deep understanding of our
partners and our customers needs
our commitment to cancer
provement has been recognized by some
efficient being award of the most
prestigious Shingo Prize which
recognizes organizations for operational
excellence
so this is my final slide and I just
want to encourage thank you for
listening to this webinar and also just
to say you know if you have an interest
in developing a molecular assay and you
have an interest in the in the products
that that we can offer and the
attributes these products have then we
encourage you to get in touch with us at
thermo Fisher our business development
partners offer a large amount of
experience and a vast technological
depth that we can impart on you and and
we can draw in expertise from various
teams within the company especially
within our Rd function to help you
develop your assays and suggest
alternatives or or even suggest
alterations in your your current sesor
so so again yeah just just please get in
touch if you're interested in and you
have interest in in the in the topics
that have been discussed during this
webinar so I will now close but I would
maybe like to call on you for any
questions if you have any questions you
like like to ask more than happy to
answer them at this particular point but
thank you for listening and I'll take
some questions now
Thank You dr. Holden for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left to your screen and I'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is thank you for the
informative webinar my lab develops
molecular diagnostics for MTV's such as
malaria our objectives are to produce MD
X's that are sensitive and specific as
well as field friendly I would like to
know if samples are available for my
Lyell ready enzymes I would like to
determine if these enzymes may aid us in
our goals
well thank you thank you for your
interest great question
yeah we offer a wide range of DNA
polymerases and reverse transcriptase in
lye ready for Matt and we would be glad
to offer samples for for testing for
sure we can sense them to you but for
more details of our line ready enzymes
that offering I would suggest that you
visit our website thermo fisher comm
backslash ly already enzymes latter one
word so that's visiting thermo Fisher
calm and the backslash lie already
enzymes and leave your contact
information and on the inquiry form and
one of our business development managers
will contact you and set you up and it
looks like we have time for one more
question dr. Holden in your presentation
you had mentioned one of the enzyme
properties as multiplexing I am working
on multiplex multiplexing Diagnostics
assays and wants to know if thermo
Fisher has any recommendation for DNA
polymerases
well thank you for your question in fact
we have platinum to tack hot start DNA
polymerase that I would recommend you
checked out this enzyme is one of our
new generation of enzymes combining both
protein design and unique buffer
composition that I alluded to in
presentation and that allows for a
universal annealing temperature platinum
fact gland and to tax popstar can be
used simultaneously similar cleanness
amplification of many targets and the
single tube using multiple pairs of
primers however I do recommend verifying
the performance of each primer care in a
single Plex PCR before starting the
multi collector reaction and don't
forget that primer design parameter is
still critical for successful multiplex
PCR yet again for more information about
this enzyme please visit our website oh
I must add to that that our R&D teams
are always ready to help in answering
specific questions such as these and
providing consultation relating to the
use of our enzymes thank you thank you
dr. Holden do you have any final
comments for our audience
but no just thank you for listening
thank you again dr. Peter Holden for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to take
laberd's and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through July of
2019 lovers will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye